jan jetzt wir sprechen die ganze zeit
über urlaubern vor allem natürlich über
die rückkehr in ihren augen wenn man
über eine zweite welle spricht wird
diese höchstwahrscheinlich dann
tatsächlich von den rückkehrern
ausgelöst oder haben wir auch hier im
land noch große gefahren
also ich krieg langsam plaques ehrlich
man muss jetzt so sagen wir reden von
einer pandemie
ja da sind lauter hopkins universität
die 16 millionen erkrankt davon sind
600.000 getötete gestorben durch diesen
virus das ist eine wirkungsvolle t 25
prozent umgerechnet auf deutschland wäre
das perfektion 250 millionen etwa fünf
zweieinhalb millionen tote also ist es
hier keinen klecker kram sondern ist
essig ungefährliche ansteckende
krankheit und wir müssen einfach
aufpassen dass wir da nicht leicht sie
nicht unsere gute nachfolger gefährt
kleines beispiel ich hatte gestern war
ein lehrerin die kam woher aus
österreich wo er am wörthersee an sich
ran und normales passiert an sich sicher
bis dann diese infektion da kann man sie
hat auch ähnliche fälle
wir haben sie noch unter dem thema wir
haben sie unter quarantäne gesetzt den
kurven abstrich gemacht und warten jetzt
ja was rauskommt und sie ist die
direktorin des gymnasiums ja jetzt
stellen sie sich mal vor du hast
unentdeckt im schulunterricht gehen also
deswegen bitte nicht leichtsinnig sein
und wirklich über den bus ist
ausgerechnet in dieser zeit im urlaub
sei eine abschließende frage sind sie
dafür dass alle urlauber jetzt zwangs
getestet werden wenn sie zurückkehren
ja